welcome to this video playing Mara
dollar and we have a little theoretical
discussion going on in the NIMS Iranian
and it's not continuing okay yes he
plays this line where he grabs a pawn
and quickly and I think that this is
kind of insanity for wise to take and he
still takes it okay this is something
different of course this is the the the
huebner variation of the new minion this
is what I'm writing the book about so
it's kind of sometimes I really should
have played something else I look at
this at the moment for all day really
all day 10 hours 12 a horse book ever
and then I play it in the blitz games
again this is really stupid to be honest
but ok let's see what I can do here he's
playing a really of beat sideline of
this of this opening not something that
concerns black very much but of course
interesting that is a complicated
position so what do I do here Queen d7
as an interesting news strategic move
very much reminiscent of a classic game
my name is a witch himself against
Dianna nimhans of which Joan onions
which dressed in 1927 if i'm not
mistaken ok so g5 it's really really
interesting strategic plane yeah I was
intending to play Queen f5 h5 for a
blockade and this is now a different
form of blockade it's getting the Queen
to g3 yet stretch true
that's definitely true knight h70 will
have f6 and maybe g5 was a little bit a
little bit too much in terms of
maneuvering
but it's not not that clear
let me think about it I one now night
h70 sf6 Alice's I can basically discard
maybe not King edge a drupe g8 okay I'm
playing it differently this g5 was a
little bit too much I underestimated
this Queenie one move quite considerably
just reroute in a kicker to e7 and
trying to get Luke to g8 and kind of
hoping that this bad bishop wants you
one and so on this city still has some
coordination issues and will not kill me
quickly
he's trying to try to sacrifice on c5
very much possible
take stakes night eggs
Jim I was thinking look h8 but he can
just take these six of course how your
take is it what I play here
can of course just take on c5 and take
on d6 Wow
it's not even a way to kind of hang on
this is really really bad night b737
bishop g6 young that's it's very simple
yeah this is also of course good time
morning is it it's nothing on the long
diagonal going on unfortunately not Wow
g5 was a really stupid idea this night
be three na for some very old fashioned
way to play this it's not giving white
anything but I just I just played it
badly queen bee 75 yeah and now I mean
g5 is simply not good because of Queenie
1g3 the general idea is not that bad I
want to play g5 age six and just keep
the knight on f6 it's a preemptive
strike against g4 but it's of course
totally unnecessary to do it the thing
is that this Queenie one is very is very
problematic simply so this is why g5 is
bad plated 11 seconds there it's not
like I played it super quickly yeah I
can play I know any normal move here and
I'm okay like h6 Queenie 7 whatever it's
all based on the fact that his bishops
are not doing very much and I have no
particular problem here if i play g5 I
have to I mean have to prepare it better
something something like this is just
just normal and good that's really not
much not much going on here here he g5
is more more coming into consideration
is if we go to analyze this kind of
position because they are all pieces on
the wall there are tons of possibilities
and it's it's it's hard to tell let's
say what what exactly should be played I
can also play maybe g6 at some point to
get rid of the pawn that's you're not a
bad idea quickly if let's say it does
that you and I can go here take sticks
and this gives me a five for the for the
bishop so never underestimate that this
is really really a bad piece on c1 so on
I think I have no particular problem
here stockfish actually likes white but
this is just a computer misconception
this closed position I don't don't think
that widest is having anything here to
be a very surprised okay well thanks for
watching